well the raiders are enjoying a couple
days off with their final preseason game
coming up this sunday it's right here on
channel 8. sports director chris
matthews has more on their game in la
against the rams but it was a raiders
crowd chris yeah brian it really was
when you think about you gotta figure
that any game played in los angeles that
involves the raiders it will be a las
vegas home crowd yeah the raiders
they'll show up that was the case this
past saturday raiders played at that new
sofa stadium against the rams but it was
a raiders home crowd las vegas did
enough to win the game but suffered a
few injuries like this one former rebel
javen white could be out for a while
hurting his knee here which is a shame
because he was playing so well
javen white
looks like he hurt his knee so we're
right now we're going to look at our
injury situation at linebacker we've had
great practices we had two really good
practices against the rams so we got to
look at the health of our team most
importantly and
we got to see who's on the bubble who we
really need to see to make this football
team and we would like to get some of
the guys a few reps but at the end of
the day i think health and
keeping the right 53 is at the top of
our list right now all right raiders and
niners preseason game as brian mentioned
just earlier shown right here on your
network home for the raiders don't
forget 1 pm here on channel 8 this
sunday raiders wrapping up their
preseason against the niners right here
on channel 8